tonight with a new Iraqi government in  place and following consultations with  allies abroad and Congress at home I can  announce that America will lead a broad  coalition to rollback this terrorist  threat our objective is clear we will  degrade and ultimately destroy ISIL  through a comprehensive and sustained  counterterrorism strategy first we will  conduct a systematic campaign of  airstrikes against these terrorists  working with the Iraqi government we  will expand our efforts beyond  protecting our own people and  humanitarian missions so that we're  hitting ISIL targets as Iraqi forces go  on offense moreover I've made it clear  that we will hunt down terrorists who  threaten our country wherever they are  that means I will not hesitate to take  action against ISIL in Syria as well as  Iraq this is a core principle of my  presidency if you threaten America you  will find no safe haven